hey guys I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen I have had so much fun
over the past two years sharing these
awesome videos with you and I know a lot
of you love the blooper reels at the
beginning so I thought I would compile
all my favorite little bits into one
colossal steaming pile of fun so without
a do here we are
hey I'm trying to deliver here snap Kris
dance real cheese ten skilled she stands
whoa
happy time girl she's dense grilled she
stands grilled she's kids know right as
some as a lot then apples milk how do
you like them apples cheese lovers some
people catch pokemon i catch Nutella
[Music]
shake it back
shake it back I'm getting really good at
that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
as you talk which a lot climb so I'm
just a hick in Canada okay I am ready to
dig in it to bottom in to drink up
let's you only have people over for
Thanksgiving so that they bring stuff to
the buffet balsa Oh
chloral balls don't you got going on in
there what did the putter corn so guys I
hope you enjoyed my little fun blooper
reel if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some ideas for other fun videos that you
want to see me get involved with and
let's be honest there will always be
bloopers and of course subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
you